kommt immer auf den laden sie haben es
echt drauf trinken dürfen das führt doch
sein
also ich die hier habe ich mental ist er
damit ist käse relativ gut gehört hat
man schon aber herzlich
hallo
antalya food tour 2021 wir tasten uns
ist die leckersten hotspots in antalya
wir freuen uns haben wir vorab gefragt
habt ihr vorschläge wer selber
recherchiert wo du zu dieser kasten
sachen die ganze welt sagt wir christen
uns durch und zeigen wir euch was man
einfach alles fürs essen kamen autos
film genau zwei tage
[Musik]
also das nicht gerade weil food in boxen
guck mal was schönes bestellen
aber irgendwas kitschiges oder auch sehr
oft empfohlen von euch
wir haben hier als meine fantastic pizza
bestellt die teilen wo insbesondere
handelt sind hier komplett
unterschiedlichen toppings drauf also
wirklich auf verschiedene fleischsorten
stoke und hähnchen und fleisch oder
nochmal anderes fleisch hier rechts ist
neuer trend seit ungefähr zwei jahren
das ist man aber die knusprige
frittierte variante die ist man hier
einfach mit joghurt und das sind akkus
netz käse und fleisch überbacken und mit
typischen gewürzen man tapeziert
schmeckt so kalt ist dann noch mal
probiert kommt immer auf den laden einem
sie haben es echt drauf schmeckt
skizziert aber immer noch leicht das
muss man erstmal schaffen steht so
schmeckt uns immer einfach noch voll
schwer finde ich also ich habe den crash
ist der winter ganz alles was ist so
besonders weil es halt gleich stück
enthält aber es muss sein
er ist lecker aber es ist okay ich
glaube dass die richtig geil weil hier
drunter ist ein richtiger takko chip und
das ist einfach überwachen noch mal
abgesehen von ein paar kurzen einfachen
takko überbacken und fleisch und käse
auch mal kantig bevorsteht fliegt abend
also für die tachos gewissen glatte zehn
das mache ich mir zu hause selber
erstmals hundertprozentig 100 prozent
ist
[Musik]
das machen wir hier bloß los wir sind
hier bei einem laden endlich handeln
muss an der wied ist gottes zu mächtig
ist also noch alles ist türkische wort
für pudding problem ist wirklich nur
deren spezialgebiet das ist das problem
in der türkei machen die politik immer
ohne ein
da haben sie mich auf jeden fall haben
wir jetzt gesehen in der türkei sowie
schokolade auch dort angekommen sollten
wir einmal modische gestellt und das
habt ihr mir auf insgesamt holen wo
halle will mit ganz vielen klicks
wir haben das genommen wo ich gefragt
was sie denn hier am meisten verkauft
und das ist jetzt bringt er mir das was
am meisten
was ist da drin ist es vielleicht
profitieren
dieses profitieren die kommen wann immer
gefüllt mit vanille
es wäre ja auch echt frankreich gegeben
denn dass man vor den wählern
ich könnte mir gut aber ich habe ja gute
geschmack kommt nicht durch robert so
einem leicht säuerliche geschmacksnote
wie kommt es also geschafft
also früchte kräftig ja brokkoli
schmeckt richtig ja also ich denke sehr
frisch weise schön kalt ist jetzt im
sommer ist es einfach mehr aber ich bin
dieser rodenstock kommt nicht durch
da weiß ich gerade finde ich ja das ist
irgendwo sagen kannst du das wirklich
der frage ist doch ob kommt also ich
finde - das ganze irgendwie so ein
charakter da ist der pudding ist aber
ich muss sagen oder dass man hier also
bei dem es ist nichts wo ich sage aber
das ist ein skandal
ich finde dass dieser für mich anfangs
dicken bist und ich kann mir geschmack
schon glaube du bist du meinst es ist
halt was das meiner kindheit kenne ich
kenne ich möchte auch gut aber ich hab'
ich hab' ich habe dir doch jetzt kommt
was über das was man isst aber es gibt
nur wenig gar nicht so richtig der bild
es moderieren
also lasst uns etwas zu viel zu sagen
aber ich glaube es ist auch möglich bei
schokolade also ich glaube dass ich mir
hier genannt und damit so aussieht aber
es ist toll hier drinnen aber geht auch
nicht mehr gehen x-mal jetzt heim und
sie haben noch ein
also teurer
[Musik]
gerade in den laden da heißt taj mahal
und eigentlich bin nicht so ihren
kapellen türkei wieso sagen wie sie
heißt etwas was man nicht mal englisches
essen anbietet und passend dazu das
erste screenshot das ist fast gar nicht
und dann kommen wir hier ein die haben
halt auch dort doch gewagt aber wir sind
schon recht spezialisiert auf
pilgerfahrt hatten all diese sachen
obwohl die auch herzblut haben und man
kann auch die leckerei company abgesehen
das sind alles richtig frisch zubereitet
arbeit mehr haben so richtig ruhig hier
sachen bestellt einmal kokos knapper da
ist einfach nur bananen das wusste ich
vorher gar nicht und haseloff und ich
habe gerade noch karten bestellt das ist
etwas kann ja dann treibt wo man richtig
durchgucken kann probiert
doch nichts war
glück auf also ich mag keine warme banal
gelingt ganz erlebt also ich feiere das
sofort
[Musik]
ich habe zu hause los genau hin wir sind
sehr sehr interessant wo ich mal
es ist lecker alle male und es ist schön
knackig müssen
ich weiß nicht was mich dass einer oder
sonst recht das ist so also ich gehe
hier habe ich variante ist er dann mit
frischen käse mozzarella käse
ja das ist jetzt will keiner gemacht
worden mit ein bisschen süße das wieder
denke ich mal
ich liebe aber nicht die kokons immer
geil ist jetzt im sommer touch weil es
ist halt so kokos und warme fokus so was
neues das coole ich kann hier wirklich
so eine bühne für trainer und dann durch
drei teilen sich sechs fällen können es
alle möglichen varianten aus ludwigsburg
auf fokus und haselnüsse es ist
überhaupt sich einzuordnen in die
kategorie klassische schöne weihnachten
gesagt mozzarella oder akw käse oder gar
kein klassisches könne für viele ist
aber interessant wenn ihr auch so
knusprige das herz steht dann probiert
das auf jeden fall auszuholen und dass
man jetzt diese politik darauf so bald
noch gesagt könnt ihr noch ein bisschen
schokolade und ob machen haben wir auch
gemacht
auch hier das zeug zum ski piste
bekommen jetzt auch frischen geist
das ist einfach das los das heißt dass
man zuvor nicht nur das vertrauen von
allem etwas
firewire ich bekomme einfach geil das
ist hier drin ist habe ich keine dieser
türkische hübschen mascarpone art
schokolade geile kombi die mucke endlich
mal durchführte hat war es heftig ich
bin aber auch nur diese schokolade gibt
noch so diesen touch einfach es ist also
football ist einfach geil in den
rollstuhl macht schokolade macht richtig
also wenn man das so sieht wenn man sich
so politische klasse wenn es möglich
ganz er nicht aber ich weiss ich
verhalte mich war die musik wieder an
der vielfalt 50 gewerbe hat man es ist
auf jeden fall und die pistenrettung
sehr gut aus das sind nicht diese
altenstadt er vorgehabt
[Musik]
gerade als holen
ich habe große familie angepasst und das
harmoniert einfach nicht und das
schmeckt so ernsthaft dass alles okay
nächste station zu station
[Musik]
zum frühstück wenn ich mir jetzt den
balkon a coffee
das rezept dazu habe ich auch schon noch
im kanal das sollte eigentlich so
aufgeschlagen aufgeschlagener instant
kaffee wein im schnitt gut richtig gut
gibt's halt kein kartenlegen geschmack
aber l10 feuer entdeckt hätte den kampf
in tschetschenien oder kaltes haben
davor gewarnt da ist einfach alles drin
was so weiß raich ist
ich bin super positiv ausgewirkt weil
wir einen zeugen wurde es gibt doch bolt
sind und es gibt auch die gesunde sachen
wer ist halt selbst auf die partikel
sind um gesundes die pläne aber als
mittel auch mit schweizer pass gesungen
als auch global
es ist eigentlich alles hinten
solarstroms wird immer alles richtig
lecker ganz ehrlich also wenn ihr hier
seid könnt euch den football ist gut das
ist so gut gehört dass sie daran gemacht
haben
das orientalisch gehört und als absolut
von den anderen teams mit dem remis auch
noch für gemüse möhren paprika und
schönfelder joghurt sei aber
gleichgeblieben sollen wilfried bauer
sein soll und den sirup kalorienarmes
aber dieser partikel euro schmeckt
genau wie wichtig ist und wann hat man
schon hast du warum also kostet so dass
die etagen der name ist jetzt erklären
oder
das ist keine rolle weil mir wichtig
dass ne pizza mäßig und es ist ein
bisschen mexikanischen der sache nicht
aus dass es noch sehr viel vielleicht
europa ist hat noch viel zeit er
schmeckt die süße de la mode und wenn
man mal keine
[Musik]
unten runde eis ist hellwach und on top
und sehr lecker schmecken nicht dass man
guckt wie du dass seine maschine werden
so kann es weitergehen
[Musik]
aber wir haben jetzt einen berlin dünner
und ich wollte mal machen wir das schon
etwas knapp werden schmeckt also ich
muss sagen ich hab dann gelingt wäre
natürlich ist aber ich finde ihn heftig
also droht sehr knusprig sehr weit
das ist ja sehr sehr sehr genutzt folgt
ohne witz leute das ist ein weg finden
sich jedes habe jetzt also ist wirklich
sehr sehr lang also ich weiß nicht ich
habe lange nicht gegessen wie gesagt man
kann sagen jetzt auch noch schmecken
also man merkt schon schöner macht
schöner
mit diesem wissen weil ich das gefühl
mit den ganzen verziehen jahren in
deutschland da bist nicht so gefeiert
wie ich zum ersten mal wieder nichts
ausgemacht aus der vier kapellen die
geschmacksrichtung wassermelone mango
werden platzen richtig schönem und also
die haut von der perle oben oder
bitte beachtet nicht unseren schönen
freund der mir gegenüber der liebe
gerechnet ist inzwischen aber diese haut
von den vier kapellen geklebt und im
glauben eigentlich darf das nicht sein
wir schauen mal eine freude dass diese
bilder sieht kann man das essen
ja klar
[Musik]
da haben wir in diesem bis zum riesen
wie sie
es ist einfach dieses machen das mal auf
ich mache ich auch so heftig auf chanson
das ist ein geschmack aber auch zitronen
schokolade es in wien ist und wie es mir
diese vorgestellt weil wir sie ist nur
eins und so kam es also falls jetzt
denkt dass man zwei tage antalya futur
wir sind genau 24 stunden hier
angekommen noch genau während 24 stunden
lang durch anteile gegessen und wir
hoffen euch das video gefallen wir
müssen jetzt zum flughafen wissen wollen
nach der rolle der kultur im
geschäftsreise gefallen und schaut euch
das video ja ja wir haben auch einen
guten block von monaco hatte von design
hast du bist du hier werden das ist
nicht alpinen ski er spricht 30 sprachen
[Musik]